[Applaudissements]
bien mes amis quel plaisir pour moi
d'accueillir d'accueillir guilhem vous
savez je voulais dit tout à l'heure pour
l'ancien président des jeunes
agriculteurs que je suis d'être à
l'origine de la création d'un mouvement
jeune autonome lorsqu'on a relevé ce
défi il ya deux ans bon c'était pas
évident c'était dans le projet je
l'avais en tête et puis vous avez montré
l'un dernière votre capacité à mobiliser
votre capacité à organiser des élections
de manière remarquable
votre capacité à rassembler votre
capacité cette année à multiplier par
deux le nombre de présents aujourd'hui
et surtout guilhem leur dira peut-être
tout à l'heure mais a passé de moins de
2000 de 2000 jeunes à dix mille jeunes
mais aujourd'hui on vous le dois à tous
et à toutes mais on le doit bien sûr
vous le comprendrez surtout à votre
président à son bureau national à son
équipe guilhem
bravo bravo et c'est super
[Musique]
cher président chers jeunes républicains
chers amis du fond du coeur je veux vous
remercier d'être ici présents ce
week-end vous n'êtes plus de 1500 cette
rentrée est un immense succès grâce à
vous un succès d'autant plus émouvant
car beaucoup nous avait enterrés
condamné à disparaître et bien aux
prophètes de notre disparition nous leur
offrons aujourd'hui la plus cinglante
des réponses oui la jeunesse de droite
est bien vivante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chers amis vous me permettrez d'abord de
saluer notre président christian jacob
en reprenant les rênes de notre famille
politique en 2019 il a engagé notre
reconstruction
reconstruction sur le fond afin de
préparer l'élection présidentielle
est bien avec sa pugnacité et son
expérience christian jacob a su
rassembler les républicains les
résultats ils sont clairs victoire aux
élections municipales victoire aux
élections sénatoriales victoire aux
élections régionales et victoire aux
sélections départementales
la droite elle est de retour
christian jacob est aussi celui qui a
fait confiance à la jeunesse il nous a
lancé un défi celui de l'autonomie et ce
défi nous l'avons relevé ensemble il ya
seulement neuf mois notre mouvement ne
comptait que plus que 1500 adhérents je
vous avais promis en avril et une
promesse astien que nous formerions à
nouveau le premier mouvement politique
de jeunes en france c'est fait nous
sommes dix mille jeunes républicains
[Applaudissements]
voilà notre victoire voilà le signe
d'une génération qui seul m
je vais maintenant avoir une pensée pour
notre ancien président laurent wauquiez
je vais salue avec affection
laurent wauquiez vous le savez c'est
toujours distingué par des convictions
fortes des convictions courageuses
aujourd'hui ces combats sont partagées
par tous et l'histoire lui donne raison
charles laurent nous avons besoin de ton
panache six français du sens de
l'honneur qui t'anime et de sa solidité
merci d'être parmi nous dans la famille
[Applaudissements]
du panache des convictions fortes le
sens de l'honneur je veux rendre hommage
aussi à bruno retailleau boussole
intellectuelle de notre famille
politique
à gérard larcher monument de sagesse
garant de nos principes républicains
je veux dire aussi mon admiration
[Musique]
vous me permettrez aussi de remercier ma
famille qui m'a transmis des valeurs
fortes
l'amour de la france le goût du service
le respect et la fidélité
[Applaudissements]
en évoquant cette qualité la fidélité je
pense à julien aubert prix en député de
vaucluse dont le combat inlassable fait
de lui un mousquetaire du gaullisme je
n'oublie pas qu'il ya trois ans julien
aubert m'a donné sa confiance le premier
et je veux le remercier devant vous de
tout coeur
chers amis aujourd'hui je vous la vous
je suis heureux et rassuré de voir
devant moi toute ma famille politique
réunie j'ai entendu dire que certains
d'entre vous étaient candidats à une
primaire quel que soit le mode de
sélection de notre champion les jeunes
républicains ont une seule exigence un
candidat un seul pour la france un seul
pour battre emmanuel macron l'année
prochaine et pour redresser la france
depuis déjà quatre ans emmanuel macron à
fracturer le peuple français c'est le
président de la division
emmanuel macron c'est celui qui traite
les ouvrières de gad en bretagne
d'illettrés c'est le président de
l'arrogance c'est président du mépris
emmanuel macron c'est celui pour lequel
il n'y a pas de culture française c'est
un président sans mémoire c'est un
président sans héritage emmanuel macron
c'est celui qui veut déconstruire
l'histoire de france c'est celui qui en
a qui en algérie affirme que la
colonisation a été un crime contre
l'humanité c'est le président qui nous
humilie emmanuel macron c'est celui qui
voulait incarner un nouveau monde il
n'est en réalité que le président de
l'effondrement français les français ont
peur certains baissent les yeux et se
taisent en rentrant chez eux l'autorité
de l'état qu'elle est à quelle autorité
quand on est fort avec les faibles et
faible avec les forts depuis de longues
années l'insécurité et nourri par une
immigration massive et incontrôlée
elle engendre le communautarisme et
brise notre modèle civilisationnel
c'est près de 2 millions d'étrangers en
un quinquennat qui ce ton qui se sont
installés légalement ou illégalement
dans notre pays
chers amis la république c'est
l'assimilation notre nation notre
république sont en danger lorsqu'on ne
sait plus assimilé lorsqu'on ne peut
plus assimilés chers amis pour nous
l'identité française c'est une histoire
c'est une terre c'est une culture
partagée c'est un plébiscite de tous les
jours pour reprendre les mots d'ernest
renan
notre effondrement n'est pas seulement
culturel il est aussi industriel
l'industrie a longtemps été notre
orgueil national nous le devons au
général de gaulle nous le devons à
pompidou l'industrie c'est
l'indépendance de notre énergie
nucléaire
la seule énergie décarbonée l'industrie
ce sont les avions de marcel dassault et
d'airbus ce sont les fusée qui décolle
de guyane ce sont les tgv vendu dans le
monde entier et ce fut longtemps la
pharmacie au premier rang dans le monde
notre industrie s'est effondrée parce
qu'on n'a pas su la protéger de nos
concurrents déloyaux or l'industrie
c'est le moteur de la recherche
l'industrie c'est le moteur de la
progression sociale quand un ouvrier
peut devenir contremaître et un
contremaître devenir ingénieur
l'industrie c'est l'enracinement dans
nos territoires
emmanuel macron se vante d'avoir baissé
les impôts mais nous sommes les
champions des prélèvements obligatoires
parmi les pays le cd eux 45% et nous
avons les services publics les plus
bureaucratisé les plus inefficaces du
monde occidental pour les contribuables
c'est la double peine
comme l'a souligné avec finesse
l'excellent maire de cannes david
lisnard à travers la crise sanitaire que
je salue qui vient d'arriver
françoise et bellamy a souligné à ce
titre la faillite de notre système
éducatif avec beaucoup de finesse encore
une fois et en rappelant que l'éducation
repose d'abord sur un devoir de
transmission
transmission de notre héritage culturel
transmission de notre langue
transmission de nos valeurs
[Applaudissements]
il ya un peu moins d'un an une enquête
internationale timss a dévoilé que les
élèves français étaient les plus mauvais
d'europe en mathématiques chaque année
nous perdons des places au classement
pisa traduisant l'affaissement du niveau
des élèves français chaque année des
postes au concours du capes et de
l'agrégation ne sont pas pourvus dans un
pays où l'on néglige l'éducation ont
produit de l'injustice sociale on freine
des talents et en briser destin chers
amis que de défis devant nous mais ces
défis nous oblige je repense à ces mots
du général de gaulle qui quelques années
avant la guerre disait aux élèves aux
officiers de l'école militaire il n'ya
de fatalité que pour les lâche un ges un
mot et le cours de l'histoire et des
tournées redressez-vous contre cette
savante l'acheter c'est pire qu'une
sottise c'est le péché contre l'esprit
chez un ami oui la france peut et doit
se relever elle s'est adressée tant de
fois déjà nous sommes les héritiers
d'une grande civilisation
nous sommes les héritiers du parthénon
et du droit romain nous sommes les
héritiers de voltaire et de la liberté
d'opinion nous sommes les héritiers de
bonaparte l'enfant d'ajaccio les
héritiers de clemenceau qui descend dans
les tranchées de 1917 et des combattants
d'algérie d'afrique et d'indochine qui
se sont battus avec héroïsme à moins que
casino
chers amis nous sommes les héritiers de
marc bloch l'un de nos plus grands
historiens qui devient en 1940 le
capitaine le plus âgé de l'armée
française et qui après l'étrange défaite
entre dans la résistance est arrêté par
la gestapo puis fusillés par les
allemands en criant vive la france
nous sommes les héritiers de raymond
aron nous sommes les héritiers de
raymond aron qui suit mieux que
quiconque dénoncé le totalitarisme
communiste à l'époque où il valait mieux
avoir tort avec sartre que raison avec
lui
chers amis nous sommes d'une génération
qui ne transige pas avec les valeurs
françaises
nous sommes d'une génération qui ne se
taira pas devant l'effondrement de son
pays nous sommes la génération du new à
l'espérance l'espérance de retrouver
ensemble la cherté d'être vent s'est dit
la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
à